we all contribute to landfill but up
close there is something overwhelming
about a place like this
and in consumer obsessed america the
scale is quite something
so too the lack of effective recycling
just look at the plastic and the
cardboard here
space is cleared for more and more
because the average american produces
nearly a ton of rubbish every year
that's three times as much as the
average britain we are seemingly
unstoppable generators of waste which is
why management is so vital so this is
the most interesting work i've ever done
zachary peterson manages this vast
landfill outside houston america's
fourth largest city and he's proud of a
process that despite flaws caused by
consumer culture and poor regulation is
he says sustainable my passion for
landfills is i can affect change and it
affects
you know our community it affects you
know being a good neighbor it affects
the environment um you know i'm directly
affecting the
the world my daughter is going to grow
up in by doing
proper landfilling
under this pasture is tons of waste
among the huge challenges of landfill is
methane without effective management
methane seeps out of the earth as the
waste decomposes and it is a greenhouse
gas that short term warms our planet
faster than any other
in america alone landfill accounts for
nearly 20 percent of human caused
methane emissions but here a solution
we've watched the trucks coming in
through the morning tons and tons of
waste flattened and compacted on top of
a plastic shell that already lines the
landfill site eventually that shell will
be sealed the waste within it will
decompose
and from that the methane can then be
extracted
these stumps are the methane wells
dotted across the landscape they are the
heart of the operation and they are the
success story the
example i like to use
being if you imagine a milkshake you
have a straw in the milkshake the milk
shakes your landfill the straw is the
extraction well you exert the vacuum
using your mouth or in our case a blower
system
and you know the content is removed at
some point
on the edge of the site the gas which
would otherwise seep out of the earth is
piped into a refinery cleaned and then
sold on to power cars and heat homes
this methane capture is a technology
used increasingly around the developed
world yet beyond it is literally an
ever-growing challenge and while this
may be a success of sorts the troubling
fact is that even here so much of this
will never decompose mark stone sky news
in texas